Marjorie Taylor green
is in a very safe Republican District in
Georgia as a radical trumpist member of
the House of Representatives but for the
first time
she spent more money than she raised and
her Democratic Challenger raised more
money than she did now I don't want to
give anybody false hope because she is
in a very red District but this is not
particularly good news for her
Democratic Challenger outrages Marjorie
Taylor Green in Georgia you really love
to see this Democrat Marcus flowers
outraised Green in the first three
months of 2022 according to his latest
Federal filings flowers and army veteran
and former military contractor pulled in
more than 2.4 million dollars in the
first quarter of 2022 dwarfing says the
hill the fundraising Hall of green who
raised under 1.1 million dollars in the
exact same time span now importantly not
only is it a very safe Republican
District flowers is behind Green in cash
on hand the latest filings with the FEC
show Green has 3 million in the bank
flowers has 1.9 million and overall
green is raised about 8.4 million for
her re-election flowers is behind but
not super far at 7.1 million for his
campaign so far unseating green is
likely to be an uphill battle for any
Democrat that is absolutely true but
this may be a sign that there's an
appetite
four
rejecting radical extremist cartoonish
pathetic Pond scum trumpism which is
what Marjorie Taylor green represents
Yahoo news reporting congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green's Campaign
Committee goes into the red for the
first time clocking up a fundraising
deficit totaling 314 thousand dollars
Marjorie Taylor Green's Campaign
Committee reported its first net loss
since she was elected it spent 1.38
million in the first quarter of 2022.
and banked 1.06 million in donations the
1.06 was rounded to 1.1 in the previous
article the spending included a hundred
and forty thousand dollars for her
security
and a retainer fee to Trump lawyer John
Eastman that's that wacky guy who's like
yeah Mike Pence just overturned the
entire thing so again the district is
depending on where you look
30 points in favor of a republican it
might only be 20 it might be 40 it
depends where you look but it is a
really really heavy Republican District
I don't know how uh flowers wins but
this could be a good sign and it's also
important to understand that the
incumbent effect is very real and so
even with the same fundraising you would
probably expect green to win because the
incumbency effect is very real but
that's also what makes the fundraising
numbers even more notable for a
non-incumbent in such a red District to
be equally or even outraising the
incumbent Republican says a lot now of
course a lot of that money is coming
from out of the district
it's not a big shock that there are
people outside of that Georgia District
who would love to see Marjorie Taylor
green removed because she's such a
lunatic and
um just holding the seat gives her an
advantage and uh this is not likely the
district this is not likely to be a
Bellwether District in November there
are others that are more likely to be
what Bellwether districts were going to
talk about them but if we want to find
something good here it's that this is a
sort of celebrity Republican
congresswoman in a very red seat and she
lost net money spent more than she took
in in the first quarter of 2022 and her
opponent who is not particularly well
known at least wasn't before this
election started is able to keep up in
fundraising it's a great thing it would
be great to knock her out I'm not
counting him out but we just have to be
realistic it's an insanely Republican
skewed District we'll take a quick break
and be back after this with with much
more for you one of our sponsors is
blinkist who's been supporting the David
packman show longer than any other
sponsor blinkist is the app that lets
you listen to or read an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist is the way to absorb those
books you can't make time for blinkist
takes top non-fiction titles pulls out
the book's key takeaways and insights
and gives it to you in the form of a
text or audio explainer that you can
consume in 15 minutes with blinkist now
you actually do have time to learn about
all the things you've been wanting to
tackle on the blinkist app I just
listened to this is your mind on Plants
by the great Michael pollen super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcast two blinkist takes
long episodes of popular podcasts and
and distills them into audio you can
listen to in 15 minutes with blinkist
you can become knowledgeable about so
many different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded tribe link is for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com Pacman the link is down
below